this past june a woman named althea
bernstein
claimed that she was set on fire by four
white men while waiting at a stoplight
in the middle of downtown madison
wisconsin
at 1 a.m she said the assailants who
happen to be in standing in the middle
of the street with all the necessary
materials for whatever reason
doused her with lighter fluid and then
threw a lighter into the car
you know like they do in the movies
where they throw a lighter and then
something lights on fire
uh it doesn't really work with most
lighters in real life but that's what
she said and it set her face on fire
somehow she was left only with a few
splotchy burns on one side of her face
after her face being on fire
one would expect a bit more visible
damage from having her whole face
set ablaze one would also expect that
four flame-throwing murderous white guys
attempting to burn people alive in the
middle of the city would attract the
attention of at least a few witnesses
not to mention security cameras but the
alleged men in the alleged attack was
witnessed by no one
and no evidence of the assailants
appeared on any camera anywhere in the
city
there was also no trace of burn marks or
accelerant in the vehicle she was
driving
when she was supposedly set on fire so
police investigated the hate crime claim
and eventually closed the case because
they could not find a single shred of
evidence to substantiate it
althea's attackers vanished into the
night much like jesse
smallett's attackers and the terrorists
who hung a rope in
bubba wallace's garage it's almost as
though they never existed at all
but despite the fact that this event as
reported by bernstein was almost
certainly a hoax
and had all the hallmarks of a hoax from
the very beginning still it made
headlines
as you'd expect the races of the victim
and her probably imaginary attackers
were front and center in the headlines
the headlines only disappeared
once it became clear that the story was
turning into an embarrassment for those
who hyped it up to begin with
now i bring this case up now again
because it provides an interesting
contrast considering now the case of
stephen ammenhauser 40
53 years old mentally ill now dead
after being brutally murdered last week
two black teenagers
xavion perry and adriel riley jr a
junior
ages 16 and 14 have been charged with
entering his home
and setting him on fire according to
police they watched him burn for a
little bit
before leaving the victim was eventually
found
transported to a hospital where he
succumbed to his burns after a couple of
days
he suffered what is quite literally the
most painful death
possible no motive has been given for
the crime and there's no indication
that hate crime charges are even being
considered at this point
which doesn't mean that there's no
evidence that whether that was a hate
crime just means that they're not
they're not considering
right now calling it that i ask you have
you have you heard about this case i
mean heard about it somewhere besides
from me right now or
one of the other hosts or our website
and if you did hear about it did you
hear about the races of the people
involved
almost certainly not a search on google
turns up a few articles about this crime
which
didn't sound like this happened 10 years
ago it happened just last week
but nothing i mean nothing in any
mainstream outlet mentioning the racial
dichotomy
is that because the media has decided
that race is now irrelevant in violent
crime
well we know that's certainly not the
case all we have to do is look at the
other tragic event of the past week
which happened when a man walked into
massage parlors in atlanta and murdered
eight people
the killer is white six of the victims
were asian
two were white now here it would be hard
to find headlines
that don't mention the races of those
involved and expressly draw a connection
between race and the crime we're told
that this is the result of white
supremacy that the killer was a white
supremacist
one of many out to kill asians
the only problem is that there is no
evidence of that here's a
police spokesman yesterday telling us
what they know about the motive at this
point listen
the suspect did take responsibility for
the shootings
he stood that early on once we began the
interviews with him
he claims that these and as the chief
said we know this is still early but he
does claim that it was not racially
motivated
he apparently has an issue what he
considers a a
fiction and sees these locations as
something that allows him to to um
to go to these places and and it's a
temptation for him that he wanted to
eliminate
um like i said it's still early on but
those
those were comments that he made did he
discuss any kind of religious
uh motivation for this or was he
responsible not that i'm aware of
nothing non-political i've heard nothing
about politics
well that's what he says now typically
the person who commits the act is a
pretty good authority on what their
motivation was
also typically if someone is is and we
know this from past events
mass killings and so on attacks that are
racially or ethnically motivated
oftentimes the person who does it for
those reasons is happy to tell you that
that was the reason
so by all accounts it sounds like this
was a lunatic motivated by sexual rage
and jealousy
could still turn out that there was more
to it than that but that's what we know
right now
that would explain why he killed both
asian and white women
the disappointment from the left to the
news that this was not racially
motivated
as far as we know has been palpable for
many of them from what it seems
the tragedy is not that humans died but
that the crime isn't useful to their
narrative
i mean the media is downright excited by
happy about violent crime committed by
white men i mean they are happy about it
they like it
they can barely contain their glee in
their minds
humans are not anything but props anyway
they have no value none of us have value
to the media outside of our political
usefulness
and that's why there was a mad rush to
declare this crime not only racially
motivated
but part of a trend an epidemic a
pandemic of whiteness as the website the
root put it
sure the facts don't fit with this
narrative but so what facts can be
manipulated ignored invented lied about
as we have seen
as for the real facts it must be noted
that yes there has been a rise
in violent crime against asians but much
of that has come at the hands of
non-white people
a lot of violence against asians is
committed by black men it's just the
fact
anti-asian sentiment has been a problem
in the black community for a long time
and you don't have to take my word for
it it's not just me telling you that the
left-wing media admits this
but of course they put the blame
elsewhere so take this headline from vox
on tuesday
echoing a common talking point that you
see all over social media and the media
right now
um their headline is the history of
tensions and solidarity between black
and asian
asian american communities explained in
the subtitle
how white supremacy tried to divide
black and asian americans
and how communities work to find common
ground
okay so acknowledging these tensions
but these tensions between the two
non-white groups of people are the fault
of
you guessed it white people of course
well that's easy to determine when
everything is the fault of white people
you know i wonder if this is the fault
of white people too in february an
asian woman in milwaukee was tortured
raped beaten
and killed in a park in broad daylight
she was apparently
hanging out in the park laying on a
blanket in the park
and next thing you know she's being
taken tortured raped and beaten
two black teenagers were arrested for
that crime now there's another story
that you probably didn't hear about and
if you did hear about it most likely not
what the race is highlighted or
mentioned at all
liz plank an msnbc contributor tweeted
in response to the massage
the massage parlor killings she said
white masculinity fetishizes and
dehumanizes asian women
and it is intrinsically tied to racism
it's crucial that we don't erase the way
that misogyny and racism
operate together to justify killing
asian women now
i haven't checked admittedly but i feel
rather certain and i will eat my words
if i'm wrong
i feel rather certain that she never
said anything about black masculinity
dehumanizing and fetishizing asian women
in response to the rape and murder of
misleading milwaukee
you know the the the media has its
villains and also it's good guys
every story is already written it's only
a matter of
making reality fit into the boxes that
they have set up for it
whatever can't be fit is simply
discarded or denied
as they say when you're a hammer
everything looks like a nail well when
you're the american media
everything looks like white supremacy
and whatever doesn't look like it
doesn't exist well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matte wall show if
you did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content